Prof: Today we're going
to talk about mating systems and
the way that they interact with
parental care,
and a bit about parental
neglect, as well as parental
care,
and parental conflict over care.
So there was just a little hint
of that in the elephant example.
What kind of a mating system do
elephants have?
Anybody know?
Student:  Harem.
Prof: It's a harem,
it's a harem.
Actually it's a family
structured situation.
Normally there is a matriarch
who is a grandmother,
and then her daughters are
there.
The bulls come in during
breeding season,
and normally the males are
separated from the females.
Anybody know about how far away
one elephant can hear another
elephant?
It's thought to be on the order
of ten to fifteen kilometers.
They communicate like blue
whales, with extremely low,
intense low-frequency rumbling
sounds.
So, in fact,
they can find each other from a
long distance.
So even though a bull elephant
might be ten or fifteen
kilometers away from a matriarch
and her group of potential
mates, he can get there in a
hurry;
he knows where they are.
Okay, so today we're going to
talk about benefits and costs of
parental care.
We're going to note that the
degree of parental care varies
tremendously among different
species of organisms.
We'll see that there are
interesting reasons why females,
in some cases,
and males in others,
and in only a few cases both
parents,
care for the offspring.
We'll consider the issue of
when it pays a parent to neglect
or kill an offspring,
or when it pays offspring to
kill siblings.
And a lot of these kinds of
questions have been illuminated
by the thought of Tim
Clutton-Brock.
Here is Tim on his ranch at the
border between South Africa and
Botswana, with his group of
habituated meerkats.
And Tim has got an interesting
way of thinking that I recommend
you look into.
He likes to come up with
extremely simple explanations as
alternatives for current
bandwagons.
So Tim has published a number
of papers in which he offers
simple explanations for things
that people thought had been
selected by kin selection;
simple explanations for
cooperation or living in a group
and things like that.
And in so doing he is actually
expressing what one might call
the empiricist Cambridge
tradition, as opposed to the
theoretical Oxford tradition.
The word that the Cambridge
people have for Oxford is the
art school in the midlands,
and that the Oxford people have
for Cambridge is the
technical school in the
downs.
So they differ in their--they
differ in interesting ways.
At any rate,
that's Tim on his ranch in
South Africa.
He's worried a lot about
parental care,
and he's written a whole book
about it.
So parental care is anything
that the parent does that
increases the fitness of that
particular parent's offspring.
And investment is different
from care.
Parental investment,
which really was defined by
Robert Trivers,
is the extent to which parental
care reduces the parent's
residual reproductive value.
So it's basically measured by
looking at the reduction in
residual reproductive value.
So it's something that
increases the fitness of this
offspring,
or this set of offspring,
at a cost to any other
component of the parent's future
fitness.
Okay?
So how do they do it?
Well there are lots of ways.
They can prepare nests,
produce gametes,
take care of eggs.
There's care of young;
without getting them any food,
you can just protect them from
predators.
You can provision young before
hatching or birth.
There are lots of ways of doing
this.
You can store food;
we'll see examples of that.
You can allow the offspring to
eat you;
which is what spiders do,
and some mites.
You can set up a situation in
which offspring are eating eggs
or siblings;
that's adelphophagy,
so that's kind of an elaborate
way of providing a supermarket
for your offspring.
You can have them eat special
secretions of ovary or oviduct,
and we'll see an interesting
example of that.
They can eat secretions
produced in special brood
chambers, or they can get
nourished via placentas or
pseudo-placentas.
So we ourselves are extremely
derived in the way that we
provide parental care.
And if we look at Nature,
we see a huge range of
variation.
And we can see cases in which
evolution has taken parental
care to a certain point and then
stopped--
like this seems to be good
enough, or maybe this is the
best--
and it's not the situation we
have.
So here's some data that
addresses a pretty
straightforward question.
These are the first,
second and third eggs,
which are laid into a herring
gull nest,
and what you can see basically
is that the heavier the egg,
the higher the survival or the
lower the mortality.
So if the egg is heavy--and it
doesn't really matter whether
it's the first,
second or third in the
series--then the probability of
fledging is going to be about
80%,
and if the egg is small,
the probability of death is
going to be just about 100%.
So this is a herring gull
chick, hatching out of an egg.
And what you can see from that
simple data is that making
bigger eggs is better for
herring gulls,
and it makes a big difference
to their abilities probably to
themoregulate,
resist disease,
resist tics and parasites;
all sorts of stuff.
Now in terms of paternal
care--this is a frog,
the Coqui frog from Puerto
Rico.
And it has, by the way,
spread around the world and is
something of a pest,
because if you hear a couple of
thousand frogs going
"coqui,
coqui, coqui" all night,
you don't sleep very well.
So people in Coqui infested
areas are sleep deprived,
and they don't like it.
But it's an interesting frog
because it has male parental
care,
and the frogs,
the male frogs,
are tending a bunch of tadpoles
that are living in the water
which is resting between the
leaf of a plant and the main
stem of the plant.
So they're up in a tree,
and they're guarding this from
snakes, insect predators,
other kinds of things.
And if you remove the male at
various stages of egg
development--this graphs what
percent of the eggs are going to
hatch and turn into tadpoles.
And basically you can see--and
by the way, these are about one
to two days for each stage of
development;
so it's roughly three to four
weeks that's going on here--
you can see that if the eggs
have been allowed to develop
quite a while,
then removing the father
doesn't make that much
difference;
after the sixteenth stage
they're going to make it.
But early in the process his
presence is absolutely critical.
So there really isn't any way
that this father can abandon
that nest without suffering a
huge fitness loss;
and that's measured by these
low numbers down here.
It can be quite risky to guard
a nest.
So this is a fish with a great
name;
it's called the lump-sucker,
and it lives off of Scotland,
and it lives in places off of
Scotland where there are otters
that are foraging in the shallow
water near shore.
And the males are guarding
nests.
This is, by the way,
not an unusual mating pattern
in fish.
You have it in gobies,
you have it in sticklebacks.
Males--in some wrasses--you'll
have a male build a nest and
females will come and deposit
eggs in it, and the male will
guard the eggs.
And basically what this shows
is the number of lump-suckers
that are caught by otters,
and you can see that the males,
who are defending the nest,
have a much higher probability
of getting killed by an otter
than the females.
So this is something where
parental care really has a high
cost.
Defending the offspring can
involve death.
Now guarding the offspring is
not necessarily something that
involves provisioning the
offspring.
Here is a Cacao stinkbug in
Trinidad,
and you can see that it is
huddled over--
it's a female--and it's huddled
over all of these offspring that
have hatched out of these eggs,
and they will guard the eggs
and the nymphs,
and if you pull the mother off,
there probably won't be any
eggs that survive to produce
nymphs.
And these things will get
nailed, the babies will get
nailed by parasitoid wasps;
they will get nailed by
foraging lacewings.
There is a very diverse and
fascinating group of predators
and parasitoids that will do
things like eat insect eggs.
And here is a nice photo of an
Australian stinkbug with all of
its offspring huddled underneath
it.
Parental care is actually
fairly widespread in the insects
and in other arthropods.
Centipedes are among the really
great parents of the world.
They are nasty and they will
sting you, but they have a nest
and they go out foraging and
bring food back to their babies.
And centipedes will raise their
babies until they are virtually
the size of the adults.
So they actually get weaned at
about 80% adult size.
They have usually a clutch of
perhaps ten or twelve offspring.
So here is an example where the
provisioning is done before the
eggs hatch or are born.
This is something that a scarab
beetle does.
And there are a number of
beetles--the dung beetles,
the burying beetles and the
scarab beetles--
that will dig tunnels into the
ground,
put food into the tunnels,
and then the female will lay
her egg on the food.
So often one of the choice
criteria for the female is how
good is my male at digging a
tunnel, and is he actively
engaged in provisioning it?
So the male clears the entrance.
He's going to defend it.
Males gather fresh leaves and
bugs.
He takes them down to the
female.
She makes them into elliptical
balls,
and then lays her egg here,
into something that develops
into a grub,
and then eats up the balls and
pupates down in the hole.
Some of the more ghastly kinds
of parental care involve setting
up a situation in which siblings
eat each other.
And the eating of a sibling has
a nice Greek name,
which makes it a little bit
more clinical,
so you don't get so emotionally
involved with it,
adelphophagy;
okay, the eating of siblings.
And it is not uncommon in
sharks.
This is an early dissection of
a pregnancy in a porbeagle
shark;
and you see here an offspring
that has a big yolk sack and
it's starting to grow.
And normally a porbeagle shark
will start out with a fair
number of embryos;
something on the order of ten
to twenty.
And often only one of them
survives to be born;
it's the one that managed to
eat up all the others.
And an adult porbeagle shark is
a pretty impressive object.
This is actually not a really
big one;
okay, this is--it's about six
feet long.
Porbeagle sharks will get up to
about twelve or fifteen feet
long.
And other sharks that do this
include bull sharks in the
rivers of Central--
you can catch them in the
rivers of Central America--
and several other shark species.
You can also find this kind of
behavior in Whelks.
So there are mollusks that will
lay eggs in clumps,
and the first one to hatch out
goes around and eats the others.
So it's a method of ensuring
that there is a high quality,
appropriately balanced diet
awaiting your offspring.
These things that they're
eating have got exactly the
biochemical constituents that
you need.
And it's an interesting
theoretical issue to think of
how can the payoff in the
quality of the one offspring
possibly compensate for the loss
in numbers of the say ten or
fifteen that died in nourishing
it?
Now another way to nourish
young is to have some kind of
specialized secretion in the
ovary or the oviduct,
and that's the case in a vector
of great medical importance,
Glossina, the tsetse fly.
And it has a really very
interesting life history.
It just gives birth to one
offspring at a time.
Most flies will go around
laying, you know,
fifteen, twenty,
fifty eggs a day,
something like that.
Glossina just makes them one at
a time, and they make them big
and lunky and high quality.
And it stays in the mother's
reproductive system until its
second instar,
and it's getting fed with a
milky secretion there that it's
absorbing through its mouth.
When it's born--here it's being
born--it immediately then falls
into the soil,
digs into the soil and pupates.
So it doesn't feed at all
outside the mother.
The mother has given it
everything it's going to get.
Other things that feed
offspring with secretions in
brood chambers are pipefish and
seahorses;
and there are some frogs that
will do this.
And some of these have kind of
pseudo-placenta where there are
blood vessels that surround the
brood chamber.
And in the case,
of course, of the seahorse,
the female has an ovipositor
that looks kind of like a
phallus.
So when seahorses copulate,
the female takes her ovipositor
and inserts it into a slit in
the male's brood pouch,
and deposits the babies into
the male's brood pouch;
which is an interesting issue.
And, of course,
seahorses have lots of other
wonderful things.
The leafy sea-dragon,
by the way, which is a favorite
of aquariums and book covers,
lives off the coast of South
Australia;
so it actually is a fairly
coldwater seahorse.
Then you can take care of your
babies,
not by giving them something
before they're born,
but you can make a nice egg,
and then when it hatches you
can feed them after they're
born.
And that is something which is
done by burying beetles.
So we have burying beetles to
thank for the fact that the
landscape is not littered with
corpses.
I have been fairly impressed--I
have to trap mice out of my
house sometimes;
I have both white-footed deer
mice and Southern bog lemmings
in my house in Hamden.
And my method of disposal is
pretty straightforward.
I take them out of the trap and
I throw them in the garden.
They're gone in the summertime
within one night.
The burying beetles come along
and take care of them.
So that was a bit of the
natural history.
Okay?
Now are there overall
connections?
Are there general patterns that
we can pull out for parental
care?
Well there is,
as you might think,
as would be logical,
there is a relationship between
the mating system and the
pattern of parental care.
So if both parents care for the
offspring,
then they are usually either
monogamous in their mating
system--
so things like swans--or
they're polygynandrous,
which means that they're things
like dunnocks.
If only the female takes care,
that's usually a polygenous
species.
So the only thing that the male
is providing is display behavior
and sperm, and then the female
is on her own with the
offspring.
The ones that are male-only are
either polyandrous or
polygynandrous.
Male-only parental care
therefore usually turns up in
the few polyandrous bird
species,
or in things like ostriches,
which are not really
polyandrous but where they have
a male that will protect a large
clutch of eggs,
into which many females will
deposit eggs;
and the fish that have the same
kind of pattern.
Okay?
So sticklebacks,
lump-suckers,
gobies, things like that.
The issue of--you can think of
it like this.
Who gets stuck with the kids?
And the type of fertilization
really has quite a bit to do
with the probability that it
will be the male or the female
that is going to do the parental
care and raise the offspring.
Species that have external
fertilization are more likely to
have male parental care than
species with internal
fertilization.
And that makes sense because
with external fertilization the
female is coming and spawning
with the male,
and the object to be cared for
is then actually physically
there in a space that the male
might have reasons to want to
defend.
In internal fertilization,
the offspring are actually
contained in and physically
inside of the female,
and they're going to be there
for a while,
which gives the male
opportunity to wander off,
or run off.
And so the type of
fertilization,
for very simple reasons,
is associated with whether the
male or the female takes care of
the babies.
So one of the reasons that
seahorses are really a striking
an exception to almost
everything is that they're
monogamous and they have
internal fertilization,
but they have male parental
care.
So they are monogamous.
They will stay together as a
pair, throughout their lives.
They have internal
fertilization inside the male's
brood pouch, but it is the male,
of course, who's taking care of
them.
And the reason is the same:
basically they're in his brood
pouch and the female can wander
off.
In this case it's interesting;
she doesn't really,
she sticks around.
So here are some examples.
The swans, which are
monogamous, and then the
dunnocks, which are
polygyandrous,
are cases where both parents
will care for the offspring.
If you want to see swans
nesting right now,
just go out Whitney,
turn left on Waite,
go down across Lake Whitney,
and you can see three swan
nests that have been constructed
in the last few days.
There will be cygnets within a
few weeks.
So maybe before you leave for
the summer, if you have a break,
go out to Lake Whitney and you
will see baby swans.
The ones where the mother takes
care of the offspring are
usually harem-based.
Now the reasons for the
existence of the harems are
different in things like elk and
deer and in marmotes.
With elk and deer,
they are foraging widely,
and the females are in a group
for protection against
predators.
And the males,
of course, have a mating season
and fight with each other for
access to the females.
But they're moving around.
And the male,
during mating season,
will defend a harem.
So this will happen,
of course, also with things
like elephant seals,
where you have harem defense.
But it's a special case with a
broad-leaf foraging ungulate.
With something like a marmote,
the harem is basically based--
it's a resource defense harem
where the male is sitting on a
pile of rocks,
and he's defending his pile of
rocks against other males.
And the females live in the
pile of rocks,
and they would live in that
pile of rocks if the male was
there or not;
I mean, they use that as their
refuge.
So basically what he does is he
finds a place in the environment
that the females need,
and then he defends it against
other males.
So that is a resource-based
kind of harem mechanism.
Whereas here it's not the
resources, it's just the females
themselves that are getting
defended by the males.
The females are wandering all
around looking for food.
The ones where it's the father
only are things like phalaropes,
which are a genus of sandpipers
that nest in the North and into
the Arctic.
This is the brightly colored
female phalarope,
and in related species of
sandpipers that are not
polyandrous,
the bright color and the
secondary sexual characteristics
are in the male,
not in the female.
And when the female is
developing her bright colors and
displaying to the male,
her ovaries are secreting
testosterone,
and she defends the territory
and goes around and lays eggs in
three or four nests.
And when the males are sitting
on the eggs that she has put in
the nest, their testes are
producing estrogen.
So, in fact,
the switch in sex role is
handled by a hormonal switch,
and it's eliciting a genetic
program that is evidently
present in both sexes and can
either feminize or androgenize
the bird in which the hormones
are produced.
And that's how the switch in
mating system is handled.
Pipefish and their relatives,
the seahorses,
are also cases that have male
parental care.
And in the seahorse that's
probably a case where there was
a prior period of polyandry;
like pipefishes or like
phalaropes, where you had one
female mating with several
males, and then that developed
into monogamy.
Okay?
So how could that happen?
How could you possibly get into
polyandry and then possibly from
that go into monogamy?
Well having one female mating
with several males might occur
when one parent can rear as many
offspring as two,
when the foraging is good.
So, you know,
from the female's point of
view,
sticking this male with three
or four eggs,
and then going off and finding
another male and giving him
three or four eggs will be much
more likely to evolve when that
act of going to the second male
doesn't harm the fitness
prospects of the first brood so
much.
So the father really could take
care of that many.
It's only likely to happen if
you're starting from a position
where the males are already
pretty heavily involved;
you know, you can't make a huge
jump into this kind of mating
system,
you have to be evolving from a
mating system in which both
parents are already taking care
of the offspring.
It probably happens mainly
where therefore where the
clutches are small,
and you can produce eggs pretty
rapidly.
And this seems to be true in
things like the phalaropes,
polyandrous shorebirds and
cassowaries and in buttonquail.
More likely to happen if the
females are big,
and therefore not likely to get
beaten up by an outraged male;
and dominant.
And in humans polyandry is
actually culturally driven,
and it's associated with
co-inheritance of farms by
brothers;
and that happens in Tibet and
Nepal.
So here are four brothers who
share one wife.
And that is a very kind of
agriculturally restricted mating
system, and it has to do with
inheritance rules.
And you'll find in cultural
anthropology,
if you go around the world,
that those kinds of culturally
inherited inheritance patterns
really have a fairly large
effect on human mating patterns
and parental care patterns
around the world.
So dowry societies are quite
different from bridal gift
societies,
and where all the brothers in a
family can only inherit one
farm,
and space is restricted and
life is harsh.
Those things make big
differences.
Okay, how do reproductive
conflicts interact with parental
care?
Well we've already seen that
there can be parent-offspring
conflict over parental
investment.
So that can lead to issues of
sex allocation in chimpanzees.
You'll recall the
Trivers-Willard hypothesis which
said that if you are a dominant
female,
you want to invest more in
sons, and if you are a
low-ranking female,
you want to invest more in
daughters.
Because in a society that has a
dominance hierarchy that gives
high ranking males better
probability of mating,
and therefore better
probability of grandchildren,
you only really want to invest
in males if they're going to
have a good chance of rising in
that rank,
and that would be because you
yourself,
as a female,
are already dominant;
that gives you a good predictor
that your son might have high
rank as well.
Whereas if you are a
low-ranking female,
in poor physiological
condition, then you don't really
get very much out of investing
in a son that will have little
prospect for mating.
But you can still get
grandchildren out of investing
in daughters.
So we've been through that for
chimpanzees.
We've also discussed how
male-female conflict over
parental investment will lead to
pregnancy conflicts that are
mediated by genomic imprinting
in humans;
those are David Haig's ideas,
as further developed by Bernie
Crespi.
And there can be sib
competition conflict over
parental investment that will
lead to analyses of brood
reduction.
So it's a fairly common
observation among raptors--
eagles, and among herons and
their allies,
egrets and herons,
and among owls--that they will
lay a clutch that has
significantly more eggs in it
than they can possibly fledge.
The babies will hatch.
The parents are not able to
feed all of them equally well.
The babies will fight with each
other for access to food,
and they'll actually kill each
other;
so that out of one of these
nests, where maybe four to six
eggs might have been laid,
you'll get one to two fledging
offspring.
And while the siblings fight
with each other,
the parents do not intervene;
they just stand back and they
let it happen.
So the kin selection argument
on this is that offspring want
more parental investment than
the parents want to give them,
because the parent has 50%
relationship to all offspring.
The offspring is 100% related
to itself and 50% related to
siblings.
So on this assumption you
should see overt conflicts
between parents and offspring;
and that's broadly confirmed.
Okay?
Usually at weaning and fledging
the offspring are complaining
and the parents are shoving them
away.
And this kind of conflict is
won by the mothers in
chimpanzees.
You should see offspring that
are soliciting their parents and
actually causing their parents
to exceed their optimal level of
investment and reduce parental
fitness.
This doesn't really seem to
happen too much.
But in the social hymenoptera
one can see that the colonies
are producing sex ratios that
are optimal for the offspring
rather than for the parents.
So there's a fairly complex
theory of what the sex ratio
should be of a social insect
colony,
based on the interests of the
workers,
versus the interests of the
queen and the king.
And there are skewed sex ratios
that come out of colonies
reflecting worker interest.
So sometimes the offspring do
seem to be able to take control
of that aspect of parental
investment.
There's another prediction,
which is that the offspring
should solicit to a level that
would actually cause them to
have significant costs.
So you should see the offspring
trying really hard,
to the point where they're
paying costs in terms of their
own fitness in order to get more
investment out of parents and
essentially blackmail them into
not investing in other
offspring.
There's very little data on
that.
So Bob Trivers is the guy that
when he was a graduate student
at Harvard,
and a junior fellow at Harvard,
and was a young father with
children,
came up with the theory of
parent-offspring conflict.
I mentioned that raptors are
birds--this is a survivor of a
parent-offspring- of an
offspring-offspring conflict.
But it is set up by the parents.
Remember that if you have
siblicide going on in nest of
eagles or hawks or egrets or
herons,
that it is the parents who have
decided that there will be a
competition in that nest,
and they have done it by laying
that many eggs into it.
So this is something that's
going on in the lifecycle of
just about every single one of
these raptors.
They have been through a very,
very stringent period early in
life.
And of course in female hyenas
there is something like that
that goes on.
So this is a case where we have
all kinds of behavioral ecology
and evolutionary ecology coming
together.
So hyenas are a case of female
reproductive dominance.
In the first week of life,
the sisters fight viciously
with each other.
I learned last night that this
happens in the Iberian Lynx as
well.
One of the reasons that it's
difficult for conversation
biologists to save the Iberian
Lynx is that there are only a
hundred of them left.
And they get a female into the
breeding facility and she gives
birth, and when the cubs are
one-month-old,
they start to kill each other.
And that lasts for about a
month;
they just go at it,
and usually there's only one
survivor.
The same thing happens in
hyenas.
It appears that there's
over-expression of testosterone.
Well we know, we've measured it;
not me, but Lawrence Frank and
others have measured
testosterone levels during
pregnancy, and there's
over-expression.
And that leads to male
mimicking genitalia.
This is now used by females in
dominance signaling,
and it does have some
consequences for copulation and
birth in hyenas.
And I think some of you have
read one of the critical papers
about this scenario.
Okay?
So the female hyena's
reproductive tract has been
heavily modified.
Here is the embryo here,
and this is her clitoris,
which has now been modified
developmentally by the
over-expression of testosterone
when she was in utero,
and it is used for dominance
signaling and things like that.
This pattern--by the way,
in a group of adult hyenas,
there will be a dominant
female, some subordinate
females,
and some males who have pretty
subordinate behavior,
and it's normally the dominant
female who's doing most of the
reproducing in that group.
So there's reproductive
suppression.
And we'll now look at a couple
of other cases of reproductive
suppression.
One of them is in dwarf
mongooses.
And this is a pretty radical
case of behavior.
Okay?
The dominant female does most
of the breeding,
and being in the group is quite
critical.
They have packs of about eight
to twenty individuals.
This is one from a big pack.
Okay?
They are voracious predators.
They can eat lizards and snakes
and spiders and scorpions.
And this is the remarkable
thing about them.
If a subordinate female dwarf
mongoose has made a mistake and
gotten pregnant,
and gives birth,
and she's confronted by the
dominant female,
she'll go get the offspring and
take them to the dominant
female,
who kills them.
She goes and gets her babies
and delivers them to the
dominant female.
Okay?
So this to us is really a
radical and upsetting thing;
and it's just about the
opposite of male suicide in
red-back spiders.
Because what's going on here is
that subordinate female,
in this reproductive system and
under these ecological
constraints,
is only going to be able to
reproduce successfully in a
group;
and in order to do so she's
going to have to survive long
enough to become a dominant
female.
The only way she can survive is
to stay in the group,
and the only way that she can
become dominant is to stay in
the group a long time.
If she goes around having
babies, she's going to get
kicked out of the group.
She will die and her babies
will die.
So if the option is either both
of us die,
both me and my babies,
or only my babies die and I
survive to try again another
day,
then they make the best of a
bad job by doing this.
Okay?
It certainly isn't optimal,
from any interpretation,
but it's probably the best that
a subordinate female can do
under the circumstances.
You wouldn't think that this
kind of thing would be going on
in the social life of something
that looks so fuzzy and lovable;
you know, they really are
rather cute.
But similar things are going on
in meerkats, which are their
relatives;
you know, these highly social
mongooses that Tim Clutton-Brock
studies.
And it's just amazing how much
brutality and crime can be--
you know, from the human point
of view--
can be packed into the head of
something that's so fuzzy and
lovable.
So let's go back to our
original questions.
What are the benefits and costs
of parental care?
Well the benefit,
of course, is offspring
survival, and the cost is
parental survival.
So we've seen with things like
lump-suckers that the males will
die protecting their babies.
So why does it vary so much
among species?
Well the payoff of having a few
well-cared for offspring versus
many poorly cared for offspring
varies a lot,
and it varies a lot both
because of the incidence of
predators and parasites and
diseases in the different kinds
of environments,
and from the phylogenetic
inheritance that's shaping the
biology of those particular
kinds of things.
It's not as though the
environment in which these
babies are living is given by
Nature;
it's something that's been
constructed by evolution.
So many things have co-evolved
to create the situation in which
this payoff is either large or
small.
So why is it that the females
do it in some cases and the
males in others,
and both?
Well whether fertilization is
external or internal is quite
important;
and that really does explain a
tremendous amount of what we see
in fish.
But in things like birds and
mammals,
this is all tied up with social
evolution and the evolution of
breeding systems and with sexual
selection and things like that.
It's because in birds and
mammals everybody has internal
fertilization,
and it's other things that are
involved in explaining who takes
care of the babies.
Why is it that parents will
sometimes kill or neglect their
offspring?
Well, you know,
the simple explanation is the
standard
adaptationist/evolutionary
explanation: they do it to
increase their lifetime
reproductive success,
and that means that there must
be some very intriguing
tradeoffs and some very strong
social and ecological
constraints;
otherwise you wouldn't see them
sacrificing direct fitness for
long-term gain and fitness.
But exactly how that works
depends on the case under
discussion.
Okay?
Now humans do this, of course.
Humans will have spontaneous
abortions if the MHC genes of
the mother and the father are
very similar to each other.
So in fact the human
reproductive tract is set up to
carry out this sort of thing,
and the human cultural system
will cause this to happen,
with very high rates of female
infanticide in cultures that
have high dowries and other
reasons for favoring boys over
girls.
So the excess of boys in China
is estimated at about 30%.
So there are about 130 boys for
each hundred girls,
that are recorded in China;
especially in rural China,
not so much in the cities.
And that's what I mean by
exactly how that works depends
on the case under discussion.
It can be the immune system;
it can be the inheritance
pattern;
it can be the social system,
with raptors and things like
that.
It can be driven by food supply
and a lot of such things.
Okay, so next time we'll talk
about alternative breeding
strategies, and if you're
interested I can go to lunch
today.